let's play a few more let's play Brigham
Brigham's been waiting for a while Oh
what is this Oh am I just losing I'm
just losing unless is my move there's a
mic move no it's it's white smooth well
this is gonna end badly
I'm pretty sure white had horse meat
like I could take and I can't stop meat
but that's a nice it's very kind of
white to not meet me
wait White has rooks I only have my
lenses I was assuming that I would have
the same idea but they don't yeah I
should probably take with King or maybe
I should take with Knights yeah I should
take with Knights
preventing this and defending my dishes
that took a while for me to figure out
okay this is clearly the best move
yeah there's close to 50 people
challenging me I'm probably not gonna
get to all the games but I'm definitely
gonna do this again it's been fun I
should not have taken the rock maybe I
should have I don't know
problem is I'm in trouble I'm down
pieces I has two rooks attacking me
let's Brigham's reading okay so bring
them okay so I'm down a lot of material
that Commons compensation in the form of
reading and not much else you like to do
they quite missed an opportunity but the
problem is generally stop it
this claim might be six trying to
centralize Olli chess will restart in
four minutes I'm curious what's gonna
happen
yeah that was a problem I couldn't stop
it though maybe I should have taken okay
so I'm down HSS I'm down sixteen that's
a big number that's like the legal
driving age about to Queen again okay
play this move unleash my queen I'm
gonna fight here I mean I am gonna try
and not lose we'll see at the very least
I want to make things complicated make
it difficult for what to win look the
king is actually like fairly safe for
now my queen is active these pieces not
doing too much I always have to look on
the bright side
hey it's Charles Hinds continuing the
sub gift you got from dynamic chassis
thanks so much Charles appreciate that
oh dear can I say this
comb Mesopotamian station Oh slight
compensation
but Mesopotamia I don't know is there
this is their compensation Queen d5 like
white doesn't have any weaknesses this
is a problem a very big problem I'm
trying to use my queen
Oh Chester Catania now we're talking
it was slight time in genitals you can't
park with the email ah yeah I know what
to do emails be fine
you see fives a nice move I guess I
could've just taking the pawn ooh
opponent wants to me me mmm
well played
it's getting complicated but not in my
favor so this is a point like people
people have all like the right to
challenge me to positions are better for
them
I'm not gonna lose hope so when I played
b5 I I was threatening the rook I still
am threatening the rook let's take the
rook free rook now I'm only now now it's
it's only plus 14 opponents to me me me
chess will restart in 45 seconds oh
what's gonna happen I could just stall
see what happens maybe you'll each s
will abort the game I'm also thinking
though like I want to play Knight h6
there's some logic to that actually my
age 6 let's try it
trapping the Queen the Queen strats the
problem is White has two queens okay
yeah
so and the knight defends f7 which is
nice probably doesn't work for this I am
threatening to play Queen a1 and win the
rook I finally migrated from youtube sue
twitch thanks so much
double BB 13 yeah this migration has
been happening a lot of now let me ask
you for the people who migrated from
YouTube to twitch
do you also watch on YouTube or are
there some people who only watch on
twitch now I was a good move by the way
Alicia Lee chess hasn't restarted or
maybe did but didn't abort the game both
both both aha everyone watches both nice
it's actually kind of crazy oh I'm not
even winning the rook forego wait has
this move so I'm just down three rooks I
migrated from YouTube to twitch just
recently I am starting streaming oh nice
I have to check you out
let's take so I'm down three routes for
a bishop so the bishop has to show its
power it's not gonna end well though
unfortunately please do this please it's
a check and King is still finding like
safety I think this is probably the
safest square on the board for the King
well that can also be fortunate busyness
is a good way to avoid boredom I don't
want to trade Queens I'm considering d5
probably d5 it just kills the bishop
even more so I think I'll play Queen
Queen B for the king and still save
talking upon yeah the thing is you two
just in terms of numbers like YouTube is
just a much much bigger platform than
twitch in terms of people who consume
content and people who produce content
might which is also big but relative to
YouTube it's still pretty small that's a
debate now between King D 6 and D 5 I
think all thinking B 6 because the
bishop wants to come here
now still surviving the hope is to like
get get white low on time and then then
hope i plunders all the rooks and gets
mated play Bishop e5 like it's already
like what to do for whites King King is
now aligned with the bishop maybe I
don't even have to win the rooks just
have to meet never give up never
surrender hmm and don't tell that to my
opponent there's a question now I don't
want to play c3 but it just doesn't do
anything so it's not really questioned
like when a for the Queen here I guess
the question is what to do
I don't see a breakthrough
I want to play Bishop c6 maybe that's a
move to play let's play Bishop d6 be
funny if white takes that I'd be a queen
for three rooks and no one ever won by
resigning also yeah like the King is
very safe and two rooks are out of play
and all their work spins and wages
plunder the Queen oh I'm lose I'm losing
to rook b8 but now Bishop here yeah wait
should've taken the bishop so now okay
now the like this is this is why I
didn't resign because now it's Queen and
Bishop four three rooks and a pawn so
it's still Haas for for white but
momentum is on my side and this rook
still pin this works out of the play
this rook is being shunned by my bishop
Jinxy three is probably no c3y can just
take a few ideas here like King a seven
is also all play Kimia seven it's
question the rook also unpinning so I'm
basically chasing the rook there's white
could have played rook hh8 but the idea
just to take here no the king is
starting to look more shaky White's
rooks are not coordinating either oh now
they're beginning to coordinate
okay I'm thinking can be seven rook rook
e7
not sure what to do here not much time
either I think I'll play Queen a five
multi-purpose move it's still probably
gonna take like in order to win this
game it's gonna take a few more of
lenders from whites at least one more
blunder from whites hopefully I can
count on what has a lot of options here
so there's gonna be some options which
are bad moves that's a move that might
be a good move okay so I want to check
let's try checking
there's a cool line I think it works
I think rookie well I can just take also
a kingi - I just meet selected bond
cloud for the loss but the calculation
is takes takes the King v6 there's no
route p7 because the bishop guards b7 so
it takes takes King b6 rook takes c4 and
then Bishop f3 and surprisingly it might
just be winning yeah let's take on b2
[Music]
there's increments so you know we can
still both survive on time I don't see
how white surviving this well maybe
white has a resource zone yeah a
calculation I should probably do more
calculation especially in these types of
positions yeah so like rook takes e4 it
looks so natural but Bishop f3 it's it's
very hard to stop this Brooksie for
Bishop a3 work t2 runs into Queen b1 and
it's just mate
how did I win a Queen magic yeah how did
I win a queen how does it cleaned
Oh Bishop c6 and yeah opponent thought
that they were being sneaky but I miss
Bishop II son
hey it's Force mates wow GG I was a
miracle I was a complete miracle
like sometimes the kids are coming back
from just really bad collisions you just
have to keep the game going and going
and going wait for opportunities
thanks thanks harsh thanks Marie
I never resign miracle bits also what
was this position I like a lot of people
are keeping sentry which is interesting
but sometimes the symmetry does not
favor me I'm drinking a let's sing it's
kind of invisible but it's a macho love
it's organic a modern take on an ancient
ritual